I'm playing something with a lot of a
lot of people and today you're gonna
play called get to know your Robin Hood
cast member I swear they're harmless
questions what TV show would you love to
guest spot on I love that show um better
call Saul I love Breaking Bad
so maybe now Oh The Bachelor of course
not what I was expecting
stranger things do you not get stranger
things no nobody's hitting back I'll
call you back ah it doesn't exist
anymore but I would have said the Golden
Girls
I love the Golden Girls favorite sci-fi
fantasy film um the Dark Crystal
a Space Odyssey probably Star Wars
Empire Strikes Back oh man oh yeah can I
change one to that oh wow let me just
distill it down sure the best sequence
in any film ever my favorite one is the
start of 2001 the ape sequence and
that's a sci-fi or fantasy film I also
think Game of Thrones is really awesome
it took me a bunch of like attempts to
start it and I was just like whatever
and then I was like is there anything
that you collect vinyl I used to collect
a hotel keys okay I would never give my
hotel key back and in my rucksack when I
traveled a lot like like 20s I just had
like a load of like hotel Keys music I
suppose you know our backgammon boards I
kind of have a side thing for music
records and just crap - you know what I
mean like this here or it's random that
your order it's fun yeah yeah yeah I've
definitely got mild hoarding I got a hat
great heckle it's it yeah you have some
painful memories as well
do you own any movie or TV show props
yeah I've got a couple of little bits
and pieces there isn't stuff that I've
gone out and bought from other things
but there would have definitely been a
bunch of award I have an original 1977
Star Wars movie poster and I take I take
a clapper board from every movie that
I'm the main character in mmm no I don't
I've got a couple of you know like the
back of my my chair with my name on them
and it covered somewhere I think but
nothing I have a beach as their podium
oh nice that's so girly at the house
that's right background photo on your
phone well it's my family my kids I was
going to show you but that'd be weird
ah it's a beautiful shot of La that is
taken by my great artist friend Richard
Louderback is there a TV show that
you've watched all all the way through
more than once
besides the Golden Girls all the way
through more than once
yeah bond the brothers I thought I did
that twice what's the most you've ever
spent on sneakers or shoes Oh probably
around a grand I think what film scared
you as a kid
mmm the witches oh man you know the kids
turn into mice sure well I just pulled
over I saw The Exorcist way younger than
I was meant to The Exorcist
oh yeah that's a big one in it in this
particular scene which now I can
appreciate as I got older my spins that
is that Satan it was a little mm a
little sassy sassy yeah like when he
says he says who are you and then he
mixed the drawer open yeah and then the
priest was so cool he said did you do
that and he pushes back
do it again and then went into
oh oh yeah satan is sassy it
[Music]